[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur france 24 sur
radio france internationale nous sommes
au siège des nations unies à new york
est notre invité aujourd'hui et son
secrétaire général antonio gutiérrez
merci à vous c'est un grand plaisir
d'être avec vous et avec moi pour cette
interview christophe boisbouvier de rfi
monsieur le secrétaire général bonjour
bonjour alors monsieur le secrétaire
général nous sommes à la veille de
l'assemblée générale est évidemment
l'ukraine sera un sujet principal de
cette assemblée générale je veux
immédiatement vous poser une question
sur ce qui a été découvert dans la ville
deux idiomes les cartes une région qui a
été reconquise par les fours sucrés
naine les forces russes les autorités
ukrainiennes affirmant avoir découvert
des centaines de corps dont certains
portent des traces
d'exécution et de torture le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky dit que les
russes sont des tortionnaires les
leaders de l'union européenne affirme
que les russes y compris leurs
dirigeants doivent rendre des comptes
devant la justice votre réaction
premièrement
nous avons assisté pendant la guerre de
l'ukraine des violations constantes des
droits de l'homme et
2 de la loi internationale humanitaire
7 nous avons appris cette nouvelle et le
bureau de la commissaire des nations
unies pour les réfugiés va se rendre sur
place pour faire une analyse de
l'information et j'espère que le
haïssent ici la cour pénale
internationale la cour pénale
internationale
qui est là et qui est à mon avis le plus
important instrument de la condition des
comptes
puissent avoir la capacité de faire une
investigation sérieuse et après
naturellement créé les conditions pour
que les responsables des atrocités
soient plus
sur le front monsieur le qatar général
les combats se poursuivent volodymyr et
nas qui essaient de pousser son avantage
militaire
vladimir poutine réplique d'un ton
menaçant
on va voir comment la contre-offensive
des ukrainiens va se terminer nous ne
sommes pas pressés est-ce que les
chances d'un accord de paix ne sont pas
plus éloignées que jamais est ce que
vous ne craignez pas une escalade
militaire qu'ils aillent jusqu'à
l'utilisation éventuelle de l'armé
nucléaire
je crains une escalade militaire
je crois que la possibilité de
l'utilisation de
deux bombes nucléaires est quelque chose
de tellement
inacceptable tellement affreux
j'espère que cette hypothèse ne soit
jamais considéré mais c'est évident que
comme vous l'avez dit les perspectives
d'une négociation pour la paix sont très
lointaine je crois que et les ukrainiens
et les russes pensent qu'ils peuvent
gagner la guerre
et je ne vois pas aucune possibilité de
s'établir à court terme une négociation
sérieuse pour la paix c'est d'ailleurs
la raison pour laquelle dans tous les
efforts de médiation nous sommes en
train surtout d'insister sur d'autres
mécanismes
pour au moins
réduire l'impact de cette l'air et sur
les ukrainiens et sur la communauté
internationale c'est pour ça que on
s'est engagé pour la libération des
civils qui étaient un obstacle c'est
pour ça qu'on s'est engagé pour l'accord
qui a permis l'exportation
par l'ukraine des produits alimentaires
ont fait un lien dialogue très
constructif va y revenir avec venus
européenne et les etats unis sur les
exportations russes de regrets qui sont
absolument vital
à ce moment
on a toujours parlé avec les deux côtés
là nous n'avons pas une compétence
directe sur l'importance de l'échangé
des prisonniers alors
on a une opération massive des dix
humanitaires à l'intérieur de l'ukraine
mais la perspective de
mettre sur place une médiation pour la
paix je crois que
nous ne sommes pas là alors je veux en
venir à la question du nucléaire on en a
parlé mais là de façon très concrète il
ya la centrale nucléaire de zappos ridja
c'est la plus grande d'europe on sait
que la ja a mené une mission sur place
on a appris ce samedi qu'elle allait
être visiblement ou qu'elle ait été
reconnectée au réseau électrique mais
malgré tout la menace reste vous avez
réclamé une zone démilitarisée autour de
la centrale mais pour le moment on en
est loin et n'est ce pas non on n'est
pas là la proposition que nous avons
fait que j'ai fait au conseil de
sécurité s'était premièrement il faut un
accord pour ne pas
bombarder
la centrale ou bombardé de la centrale
c'est évident
et deuxièmement j'ai dit il faut définir
un périmètre
que les troupes russes le pouce
d'où les troupes russes puisse se
retirer avec le compromis les ukrainiens
n'essaierai pas de
prendre militairement la centrale c'est
à dire rendre la centrale un instrument
strictement civil et c'est ce dont nous
avons besoin je crois pour que la
centrale puisse être réanimé comme vous
savez les réacteurs sont tous fermés
il y a naturellement des possibilités de
génération locale d'électricité pour la
fois 10 mans qui est essentiel sinon on
aurait cher mobile mais
[Musique]
la ligne principale a été
ray mise en fonction qui permet à la
réseau ukrainien de
d'apporter de l'électricité
à la centrale alors je crois que pour le
moment il n'y a pas un risque immédiat
il n'y a pas de radiation
exceptionnelle et nous appuyons
fortement l' agence
l' agence de l'énergie atomique pour que
ses membres puissent rester sur place et
ça c'est une garantie importante pour
éviter le pire alors le 22 juillet
dernier à istanbul grâce à votre
médiation et à celle du président turc
un accord a été trouvé entre les russes
et les ukrainiens pour faire sortir et
le blé ukrainien et le blé et les
engrais russe mais mercredi dernier je
crois la dîmière poutine vous a dit au
téléphone que cet accord ne marchait pas
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que le
blé ukrainien irait beaucoup plus en
europe qu'en afrique et ensuite parce
que
les blés et engrais russe ne pourrait
pas sortir de russie comme promis à
cause des blocages des occidentaux
est-ce que ce que dit vladimir poutine
est vrai
partiellement vrai
mais nous sommes en train de résoudre
ces problèmes
premièrement il n'y a pas un accord il y
a deux accords un accord sur
les exports ukrainien qui est un accord
entre russes ukrainiens et les nations
unies et la turquie est un accord entre
les nations unies la russie
pour que les nations unies fasse de son
mieux vis-à-vis les etats-unis vis-à-vis
l'union européenne et les autres pays
qui ont établi des sanctions pour que ce
qu'on dit publiquement toujours que ces
sanctions ne s'applique pas aux engrais
et aux produits alimentaires puissent se
traduire en pratique la vérité c'est
qu'il y a des difficultés pour des
questions indirecte des questions de
paiement des questions d'assurance des
questions de
accès
un déport parce que beaucoup de de
ses exportations sont faites par le
biais par exemple l'union européenne et
nous avons eu une négociation très
importante et très sérieuse avec l'union
européenne et les etats unis et je crois
que nous sommes sur le chemin de trouver
une solution pour les problèmes qui
restent encore nous avons réellement
besoin des engrais le marché les engrais
est dans une situation terrible en
afrique on voit partout qu'on est en
train de cultiver moins que l'année
dernière il faut il faut rétablir la
normalité dit aux marchés des engrais en
même temps
il faut dire que il y a eu des
exportations de
produits alimentaires
ukrainien vers tout le monde d'accord
faire des pays européens vers d'autres
pays riches mais aussi
vers des pays de revenus moyens comme la
chine ou l'inde où l'egypte et vers des
pays plus pauvres et le
programme alimentaire mondial a déjà
fait sortir trois bateaux vers le corne
de l'afrique vers lee et mène maintenant
un troisième vers djibouti il y à un
quatrième qui se prépare pour
l'afghanistan alors je crois que si
c'est vrai que beaucoup des exportations
ont été pour les pays européens mais
tout ça vient des contrats commerciaux
la vérité c'est qu'on est aussi en train
de exportons voit les ukrainiens sont
dits en train d'exporter vers les pays
de revenus très bas ou de revenus moyens
et il y à l'autre aspect qu'il faut
reconnaître même quand on vend à un pays
européen ça un aspect de
d'impact sur le marché mondial qui
aident à que les prix baissent c'est à
dire l'injection de dino offre
additionnelle
quoi que ce soit le pays de
deux
destinations a un effet positif sur le
marché global donc tout le monde
bénéficie y compris les pays moins
développés je veux revenir rapidement à
l'accord nucléaire sur l'iran il ya eu
des négociations qui semblaient
encourageante mais dorénavant l'espoir
d'un accord
s'envole ici à new york il y aura sans
doute les acteurs principaux de cette
négociation est ce que vous êtes inquiet
et est ce que vous espérez que ici on
pourra peut-être faire le progrès qui
n'a pas pu être fait
je suis en contact permanent
et avec l'iran et avec les pays qui
négocient les insomnies non pas une
intervention directe
et pour parler de toute franchise il y a
deux semaines
j'étais convaincu qu'on allait arriver à
un accord
après
les choses se sont compliquées
j'ai encore de l'espoir mais peu mais
mais je crois qu'il y a des difficultés
énormes et qu'il faut vraiment un effort
additionnel pour les surmonter
moi je pense que
je sais pas comment on dit en français
jessy piot et l'accord sur le nucléaire
ap l'accord sur le nucléaire
a été une des grandes victoires
diplomatiques
dernières années que c'était vraiment
dommage que les états unis allaient
abandonner avec la réaction iranienne de
recommencer c'est ses activités dans ce
domaine et que c'est vital de le
rétablir à mon avis c'est une question
vitale et j'espère que cette semaine
puisse nous aider
à aller dans la bonne direction à la
suite des inondations meurtrières au
pakistan vous vous êtes rendus sur place
c'était il ya quelques jours vous avez
dénoncé les effets désastreux des
concentrations de gaz à effet de serre à
glasgow à la coop 26 l'an dernier les
pays développés se sont engagés à verser
tous les ans 40 milliards de dollars
pour les pays les plus pauvres pour
qu'ils s'adaptent
mais est ce que les promesses sont
tenues en revue de sharm el cheikh en
vue de la coop 27
bon premièrement il faut dire que
le problème central de la lutte contre
le changement climatique
et à ce stade dans une situation que je
considérais désastreuse
nous avons besoin de commencer
immédiatement à réduire les émissions
nous voyons la dévastation gigantesque
au pakistan mais nous voyons aussi la
sécheresse en afrique quatre ans de
sécheresse au corne de l'afrique le
cinquième est en train de démontrer plus
ou moins la même situation est opéable
après les tempêtes les incendies des
forêts etc alors vraiment
au moment où il faudrait commencer à
réduire les émissions les émissions
continuent à augmenter au moment où on
devrait se dégager d
des des combustibles fossiles on voit la
renaissance des combustibles fossiles
alors on va vers le désastre si on ne
change pas de cap et nous n'avons pas
beaucoup de temps parce que il y a des
effets irréversibles
il y a ceux qu'on appelle les
tippingpoint
sur les questions climatiques qui
peuvent rendre
impossible de maintenir
le niveau 1,5 alors
quand on a besoin de 45 % de réduction
des émissions
jusqu'à 2030 nous avons face aux
engagements actuels une perspective de
croissance de 14% ça c'est vraiment le
suicide et on dit ça ça ça rend encore
plus important l'appui aux pays qui sont
dans les points les plus
impactés par le changement climatique
pour les aider à bâtir une résilience
des infrastructures
durable et renforcer la capacité des
communautés pour survivre et c'est pour
ça que nous avons toujours dit qu'il
faudrait que la moitié des fonds
climatique soit pour l'adaptation
malheureusement on n'a pas encore réussi
ça il ya la promesse des 40 milliards ce
n'est pas encore clair si cette promesse
va être tenue ou non et c'est pour ça
que nous demandons et je vais le répéter
dans deux jours il faut que les pays
développés
démontre qu'elle est la façon dont ils
vont respecter cet engagement est aussi
l'engagement des 100 milliards
vis-à-vis
ce qui a été accordé à paris qui devrait
commencer en 2020 qui n'a pas fonctionné
en 2020 qui la bat fonctionne en 2021
qu'il n'est pas en train de fonctionner
en 2022 et ça c'est une chose qui minent
la confiance et on a besoin de confiance
aujourd'hui parce que on n'a pas
seulement besoin de réduction des
émissions dans les pays développés vita
c'est la réduction des émissions dans
les économies émergentes
les fines les russies
dans les indonésiens et serra et il faut
absolument établir des mécanismes de
coopération entre les pays développés
ces pays là pour qu'ils puissent
commencer à réduire les émissions bien
plus tôt que ce qui est promis à ce
moment là ce dialogue est essentiel et
pour que ce dialogue puisse fonctionner
il faut rétablir la confiance et la
confiance aujourd'hui n'est pas là le
prix coop qui a pris place ne s'est pas
bien déroulée il y à vraiment le risque
je dirais encore pire que le risque
d'une division nord sud
c'est la division ouest sud
le haut commissariat de l'onu aux droits
de l'homme a publié un rapport très
attendu sur les crimes commis par la
chine dans sa région du xinjiang le
rapport parent de détention de
population en masse et parlent de
possibles crimes contre l'humanité vous
avez exhorté la chine à appliquer les
recommandations de son rapport elle a
évidemment refusé est-ce qu'on en reste
là quand on parle de possibles crimes
contre l'humanité est ce qu'il ne faut
pas demander plus dire plus il ya
naturellement comme vous le savez les
instruments qui qui dévie qui a c'est à
ces questions
nous maintenons notre position claire
c'est qu'il faut rétablir des conditions
où la communauté ouïghoure puisse voir
ses droits de l'homme respecté et plus
que ça cette communauté puisse sentir
que son identité
culturelle religieuse est respecté et en
même temps qu'elle allait condition de
faire partie de la société dans son
ensemble et que sa voix soit accueilli
dans la société dans son ensemble et
j'espère que
cette question qui est une question
essentielle puissent être effectivement
résolu et naturellement il y a les
organisations internationales qui ont
des compétences dans cette matière en
haïti la hausse du prix du carburant
provoque depuis quelques jours des
émeutes des pillages vous venait
d'appeler toutes les parties à
désamorcer la crise est-ce qu'il faut re
subventionner le carburant pour les
populations les plus démunies et est ce
que le plan d'urgence de quelques
millions de dollars que vous venez d'en
vous venez d'obtenir le déblocage est ce
que ce plan est à la hauteur des enjeux
du point de vue
je dirais deux des principes je crois
qu'on devrait subventionner les familles
et par les carburants
et ce n'est pas exactement la même chose
parce que ça permet aux familles
d'obtenir les ressources dont ils ont
besoin et ça ne se traduit pas dans une
dans un bénéfice pour
les combustibles fossiles mais dans le
cadre haïti ce que j'ai dit on arrive à
plusieurs réunions du conseil de
sécurité et je suis convaincu qu'il faut
absolument
réintroduire une sécurité sérieusement
et
la proposition que j'ai mis sur la table
c'est qu'il faut vraiment un programme
international d'appui à la formation et
à l'équipement de la police mais qu'il
faudra avoir dans cette perspective une
force
robuste capable de mettre fin à l'action
des gammes
et nous connaissons tous dans les pays
nous avons au portugal vous avez en
france des forces de police robuste et
je crois qu'il nous faut avoir en haïti
dans cette transition de formation et
l'équipement d'une police qui pour le
moment est il efficace il faut avoir une
force qui puisse vraiment mettre de
l'ordre vis-à-vis une ville notamment
mais aussi le pays compte complètement
contrôlés par des gants ce ne sont pas
des mouvements politiques ce sont des
ganks malheureusement infiltrés aussi
par des gens liés au pouvoir économique
le pouvoir politique monsieur l'agent
n'a plus beaucoup de temps je veux quand
même qu'on parle de l'afrique du mali il
ya une crise diplomatique en ce moment
avec la côte d'ivoire le mali détient 46
soldats ivoiriens qu'il appelle des
mercenaires la côte d'ivoire dit non il
travaillait au service de la mission de
l'onu la minus m'a tout d'abord très
rapidement pour vous ce sont des
mercenaires non ce ne sont pas des
mercenaires c'est évident et je fait
appel aux autorités maliennes pour que
ce problème puisse résoudre ou les avait
appelés vous avez parler au président
ivoirien on est en contact permanent
avec eux et c'est aux états avec je vais
pas parler directement à greta mais on
est en contact permanent et je vais
recevoir la délégation du mali c'est une
chose qui est pour moi très importante
il faut résoudre ce problème
et deuxièmement je crois que
il faut reconnaître que la situation
dans le sahel est aujourd'hui une
situation très très difficile
nous avons des groupes terroristes qui
sont partout nous avons des changements
climatiques qui ont un impact
dévastateur
nous avons des problèmes de gouvernance
comme vous le savez et nous avons une
situation économique terrible c'est pour
ça que nous avons constitué sous l'égide
de l'ancien président issoufou une
équipe qui puisse nous proposer à la
communauté internationale une nouvelle
stratégie pour le sahel parce que ce
qu'on fait maintenant ne suffit pas il
faut reconnaître notre faillite
collective et il faut trouver un autre
approche
parce que cette région va de mal en pire
dans l'est du congo-kinshasa les
populations manifestent contre les
casques bleus de la monusco parce
qu'elles accusent des casques bleus de
ne pas les protéger contre les rebelles
il y a eu des manifestations meurtrières
au mois de juillet et est ce que vous
allez envisager un départ anticipé de
ces casques bleus avant la date de 2024
et peut-être même avant la
présidentielle de la fin 2023 comme vous
le demande plusieurs autorités il ya un
programme de réduction progressive de la
force qui est accordée avec le
gouvernement mais parlons franchement
les populations ont le désir et la
perspective que les forces onusiennes
soit capable de battre les mouvements
qu'il laisse attaque et de leur garantir
la protection mais on est dans une
situation extrêmement difficile voyez
les 23 20 23 a été comme vous savez la
raison de ces dernières des monstres
manifestation le fait que les nations
unies ne sont pas capables de battre les
23 la vérité c'est que le m23
aujourd'hui est une armée moderne avec
des équipements nour qui sont plus
perfectionné que les équipements de la
monusco et vient-il du rwanda ces
équipements
il vienne de quelque part bon vous
semble et dit on vienne de quelque part
quelques pas d'accord ils n'ont pas ils
ne sont pas nés
dans la forêt il vienne de quelque part
alors
ce qu'il faut à mon avis et c'est
l'essentiel c'est de trouver
une discussion sérieuse
entre le congo le rwanda et l'ouganda
pour qu'on puisse avoir une perspective
conjointe pour éviter cette permanente
situation qui nous fait toujours quand
on a un progrès revenir en arrière il
faut que ces pays se comprennent
mutuellement et il faut que ces pays
coopèrent effectivement pour la sécurité
de l'est du congo aussi pour les
garanties de sécurité il faut pas
l'oublier du rwanda et de l'ouganda il
faut pas oublier que l'adf est un
mouvement originaire de l'ouganda il
faut pas oublier qu'il y à encore dans
le congo ft allard
fclr sais pas comment mais c'est comme
ça qui est un mouvement sortie des
génocidaires des hutus alors il y avait
préoccupations de tous les pays il faut
qu'ils s'entendent parce que penser
qu'une force de maintien de la paix peut
résoudre des problèmes quand il ya
maintenant des forces militaires
extrêmement bien armée
c'est impossible et les populations
naturellement ne le comprennent pas et
pour nous c'est une énorme d'ailleurs
c'est un problème général sur le futur
des opérations de maintien de la paix
les opérations de maintien de la paix
était fait pour maintenir la paix mais
maintenant elles opèrent dans des
situations la paix n'existe pas et je
crois que c'est une réflexion
essentielle nous avons
fait un certain nombre de réformes pour
améliorer la capacité pour améliorer
la leur sécurité mais la vérité c'est
qu'il nous faut une réponse une
réflexion profonde sur le futur delà du
maintien de la paix dans des situations
comme celle-là et moi je suis
entièrement favorable à qu'il y ait des
forces de l'imposition de la paix et de
lutte antiterroriste des forces
africaines d'imposition de la paix et de
lutte antiterroriste menée sous l'égide
de l'union africaine est financé par
les contributions non les contributions
obligatoires du système des nations
unies comme les forces de maintien de la
paix sans ce sens des forces africaines
robuste d'imposition de la paix je crois
que on n'ira nulle part monsieur le
secrétaire général merci de nous avoir
accordé cette interview et merci à vous
de nous avoir suivi sur nos deux chaînes
france 24 et radio france internationale